Vice has gone bankrupt part of this is a
trend in the industry when covet started
everybody was home consuming content a
lot of media Outlets grew dramatically
the David packman show is one of them
some of these media Outlets over hired
and as things settled and people went
back out into the world and covered
waned many of these companies had over
hired they had taken on debt and it was
an economic Market financial situation
that drove them to bankruptcy or at
least to downsizing Vice is different in
that dating to years before the pandemic
starting in 2017 Vice was having issues
around culture treatment of employees
and other things and that's why Vice
ended up at this perfect Crossroads so
to speak of a phenomena that affected
many of these media Outlets plus special
problems that Vice brought Vice did some
great content and my view is we want
more diversity of media Outlets not less